ADI HADDAD: I'm Adi.
I'm Games video manager.
I'm based in Tel Aviv.
And I work with Israel and
Turkish gaming companies.
And I camp and I win
games because of that.
So let's start with a question.
By raise of hands, who
wants to make more money
from their games?
Raise your hands.
Yeah.
That makes sense because
you're here today.
And the obvious
follow up question
should be, how can you make
more money from your games?
Harry Markowitz, a Nobel
Prize winning economist,
said he would never be 100%
invested in stocks, or bonds,
or cash, basically
saying he will never
put all his eggs in one basket.
And when you think about
it, why mobile games should
be any different?
Why rely on one
source of revenue
and not try to diversify
your revenue streams?
In our industry it's set
up in a very unique way.
Usually the game genres
determine the game monetization
you have.
So in hyper casual games, we
usually see ad monetization.
In RPG and strategy games,
we usually IP monetization.
And this isn't a bad thing.
But today I wanted to take
a step back and rethink
this assumption.
Ask yourself, does
that make sense
to focus on one monetization
strategy in your games?
And what can you learn
from other genres?
from other developers?
So today I'm going to talk
about why diversify monetization
strategies in mobile games.
Then I'm going to
discuss different trends
around this topic.
And then I'm going to
finish with Gram Games
on stage who are going to
share with us their journey
of revenue diversification.
So why diversify?
As Markowitz said, by
diversifying revenue streams,
you're actually decreasing
the risk you have in games.
But more than that,
you have more options
to monetize your
audience, which can
create an uplift in revenue.
Another reason is based
on the Google Play data.
And it's actually the first time
we are showing that on stage.
So let's take a look.
What you see in the
graph in the x-axis
is the percentage of
revenue coming from top 5%
of spenders in the game.
What you see in the
y-axis is the reactivation
rate of churn
bias, or how likely
is the game to get
back churn bias.
Take a picture.
That's a good one.
And what we found
out in our data
that we actually have a
correlation between the two
things.
So if you look at the
bottom right corner,
you see that games that are
really concentrated on revenue
from the top 5% of spenders
they have are actually less
likely to get back churn bias.
On the other hand, if you
look at the top left corner,
on the star sign,
you see that games
that are really
good at getting back
churn buyers are less dependent
on the top 5% of spenders
they have.
So what that means is that
trying to get $1 from a larger
audience is actually more
sustainable in trying to get
$100 from a high value user.
so what trends do we
see around monetization
and diversification?
Subscriptions,
rewarded ads, and IAP.
So subscription is quite
new in mobile games.
But rewarded ads and
IAP are not new per se.
We saw some interesting
trends with them.
And we are going to
discuss that later.
But let's start
with subscriptions.
So who is using
subscriptions in the games.
Please raise your hand.
OK.
Yeah.
A few hands.
That makes sense.
And subscription is not a
foreign concept in gaming.
We've seen that
on PC and console.
But it's actually quite a
new concept in mobile games.
And we see more
and more developers
who are using this
strategy on top of the IAP
they have in their game in
order to create the premium
experience for users.
And actually, on Google Play
we see a growing momentum,
with more than 70%
year on year growth
in subscribers and games.
And developers are
using this strategy
and reporting different
benefits of doing so.
So [INAUDIBLE],, for example,
reported that subscribers
pay 20% more than they used to.
And Scopely reported that
subscribers have much higher
LTV.
And another reason of
using subscriptions
is that it can actually
help you diffuse
the feeling of regrets in game.
So what happens sometimes
is that users binge on IAP,
and then they feel
regret doing so.
But if you use subscriptions,
you can actually change that.
So instead of eating all the
Halloween candies in one day,
user will eat one candy each
day for a long period of time.
And then they feel
rested while doing so.
So how to design
subscription experience?
So that's something that
requires a mindset shift.
You can use your IAP SKUs,
repackage them, and offer them
as subscription bundles.
It can actually work for you.
But we think that you
can do more than that.
But while IAP is more about
the ownership of things,
users are paying to own and
keep something in the game,
subscription is more about the
access to a premium experience,
access users can
gain and also lose.
And you have two main use cases
for subscriptions in games.
The first one is to convert
new buyers often looking
for really good deals.
So if you take a
look at the example,
see that Scopely on
top of the IAP deal
are offering really
exclusive rewards, like loss
protection in the game,
and also higher data caps.
And they're offering this bundle
very early on in the game,
just after a first
time user experience.
And the idea behind that is they
are trying to also make sure
that new buyers will
stay longer in the game
and play longer sessions.
And second use case
for a subscription
is to create a loyalty program
for your most valuable users.
So these users are often looking
for a premium experience,
rewards for the commitment
they have to game,
and also a prestige feeling.
And in the examples
[INAUDIBLE] for the VIP
users are offering quite a lot.
Extra currency,
exclusive tournaments,
early access to new content, and
access to a special durables.
So that's quite a lot.
So that was subscriptions.
And let's move to rewarded ads.
So is it a new trend?
You are obviously
asking yourself
why I'm speaking
about rewarded ads.
So it's not a new
monetization model.
We've seen that for a
couple of years now.
But what the Google Ad Mob
team found out recently
in the research they did is
that IP heavy developers who
didn't focus on ads
before are starting
to rethink the monetization
strategy they have in games.
And as a result,
they're implementing
more and more rewarded ads.
And that's why you see
more hybrid games today
in the industry, in
both IAP and rewarded
ads implemented in them.
So why use rewarded ads?
So we have a couple
of reasons for that.
First of all, you can
monetize your non-paying users
with rewarded ads.
You actually give
your users the option
to choose the currency they
would like to pay with,
time or money.
It can also increase
your engagement
in the game of both
payers and non payers.
Users are getting back more
frequently into the game,
and also play longer sessions.
And the third key reason
of using rewarded ads--
and you may not be
familiar with that--
is that it can actually predict
IAP conversion in games.
So what Kongregate found
out recently in their games
is that new users who watch an
ad in the first ever session
they're having in
the game are actually
much more likely to
make an in-app purchase.
And they saw an uptick
of between 250% to 500%
in that conversion rate,
which is really amazing.
So how to design a
rewarded ads experience?
We know it can be a bit tricky.
So we're showing you an
Ad Mob framework that
can help you in the process.
So you need to think
about placement
of the ads, user targeting,
cadence, and measurement.
And let's see what
Kongregate are doing
for each one of these points.
So first of all, the ads should
be part of a game economy
design, and should
give something
meaningful to your users.
But at the same time, make sure
it doesn't compete directly
with your IAP.
And every user should
have access to the ads.
But if you decide to remove
this access to paying users,
don't forget to give
them their rewards.
And more is not always better.
They found out that between six
to eight ads per user per day
is the best practice.
And lastly, don't forget to
measure important metrics,
like ad viewership
and frequency,
because you can segment
your users with that,
and optimize the
performance of each segment.
OK.
So let's talk about
IAP a little bit.
So what we see with IAP
is very similar to what
we see with rewarded ads.
An increasing
number of developers
who didn't focus on IAP
before and really focus on ads
are starting to
shift that focus.
And they're either implementing
IAP in existing titles,
or started to develop new IAP
based games for the first time.
Tapps Games, for example, a
Brazilian company, really known
for hyper casual games,
decided to double down
IAP in the "Bid Wars"
titles, which are
auction like strategy games.
Rally nice games.
And they've been working
very closely with the Play
team in their time on that.
And in less than two years, they
saw an uptick of more than 200%
in IP revenue.
So that was a game
changer for the company.
And as a result, IAP today is
part of the company's strategy.
So why developers are looking
to diversify with IAP?
So first of all,
successful IAP games
can be mentioned and developed
by really small teams,
and simple operation
for structures.
In some cases,
we're seeing teams
as small as 10 people who are
responsible for multimillion
success stories.
IAP games also rely less on
massive number of installs.
So instead of focusing
on game launches,
they're actually shifting focus
to more long term sustainable
KPIs, like game engagement.
And IAP games are also
all about taking back
control of your own
revenue, instead of
depending on other companies
to provide you this revenue.
And if you have the
right tools in place,
you have the flexibility
of testing, changing,
and optimizing your game.
So for those of
you who are looking
to diversify with IAP
for the first time,
really double down on that.
That's a basic
framework for you that
can help you in this process.
So first of all, you need to
think about game economy design
very early on in the development
process, because it's
part of a core gameplay loop.
So don't forget that.
Then think how to convert
users to be paying users,
or how to create the value for
money perception in your game.
And lastly, you need to think
how to retain your users
and repeat the purchase events.
Basically shifting the
focus from a one time event,
a game launch, to treat
your game as a service.
And we asked Yodo1, to
[INAUDIBLE] publisher,
to share with us some
insights on this framework.
And the reason we asked
Yodo1 is that they
have an amazing story.
They're also known for
hyper casual games.
And they have a leading
title, "Rodeo Stampede."
How many of you know
"Rodeo Stampede?"
It's a pretty known game.
Yeah.
OK.
And they decided to double
down IAP in that game.
In less than a
year, they managed
to shift the ads to
IAP ratio in the game.
So IAP today, 60%
of the revenue.
And only a couple of
months ago, it was 30%.
And they shared
with us some insight
that can help you also
to think about IAP.
So first of all, you need
to keep your design very
simple at first, because
then you can add more layers,
and change that
quite easy later on.
But at the same time,
try and monetize
as much users as you can by
using different currencies.
So they're using an ad
currency in the game world,
and also an IP
currency that targets
different type of users.
And they found out that in
order to convert more users
to be paying users,
it's really valuable
to understand what is
unique about each segment,
and what excites them
in the game, what
does staying and playing a
longer session in the game?
Because then you can create
targeted offerings, which
makes sense for each segment.
And last, it's really important
to invest in more content,
either by deepening the
content you already have--
so if you have characters,
add more of them--
or by adding more system
and features to the game.
In order to create a live
ops plan, with many events
and promotions,
it's really valuable
to have a system that
you can customize,
because then you don't
need to invest so much time
and effort in each
event, in each promotion.
And you can do much
more with much less.
OK.
So we discussed very briefly
subscriptions, rewarded ads,
and IAP.
And I gave you a small glimpse
into new opportunities,
hopefully to you to have
meaningful discussion
with your team
about monetization.
Ask your team, is the
current status quo
you have in your company
your best strategy?
And now I want to welcome
on stage Eren, who
is going to share with us the
really amazing journey of Gram
Games around revenue
diversification.
So please welcome him on stage.
Yeah?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So let me just introduce
you before we start.
EREN YANIK: Sure.
ADI HADDAD: So Eren is the chief
revenue officer of Gram Games.
He joined the company
two years ago.
Before that he was a
senior manager at McKinsey.
And at Gram Games, he is
leading the production,
monetization of the company.
And he also led the
transformation of the company
from an ad revenue based
company to a majority IAP
revenue based company.
So really thanks for
joining the talk.
EREN YANIK: Thank you.
ADI HADDAD: I really
appreciate that.
So let's dive into
the first question.
EREN YANIK: Sure.
ADI HADDAD: Can you
tell the audience
a little bit about Gram Games.
EREN YANIK: Sure.
ADI HADDAD: What kind
of games do you have?
EREN YANIK: So Gram
Games was primarily
founded as a company that
makes quick games, make them
fast, iterate fast, fail
fast, and then launch them
to the market separately,
with lean teams.
That's why initially they
focused on ad based games,
like hyper casual games.
I think so far we have about
nine games in our portfolio.
And eight of them
are close to fully ad
funded, and hyper
casual to casual games.
The most famous ones
being "1010" and "Six!"
Building on that, we
have recently, last year,
launched "Merge Dragons," which
is right now 95% IAP based.
So we have shifted, even
though using the core loops
and mechanics that exist
in hyper casual games,
we have actually
successfully transitioned
into a more IAP
majority revenue source.
So right now we're probably
more than 60% IAP revenues
as a studio, and 30%
to 40% ad revenues.
ADI HADDAD: So we've
been working together
for a couple of months now.
And we had different
discussions on that decision
to diversify with IAP.
So can you share with the crowd
a little bit why you did it,
what were the reasons
behind that decision,
and when did it happen?
EREN YANIK: Sure thing.
So ads business is,
I mean, in my view,
it's very useful if
you're one of the two.
Like you're either a small
company, small studio,
with people that
focus on quick games,
smaller games,
launching them fast,
like the initial stage
that we used to be.
Or if you are a publisher
that can really churn out,
can really produce
games really fast,
like one game a
week or something,
and you can rely on publishing,
other studios to help you.
But if you're somewhere
in the middle,
probably focusing on
one game or a few games,
and focusing on a more
stable revenue source
that is not affected
seasonally, or that does not
rely on other intermediaries
between yourselves and players.
Because ad revenues,
you can't really
control what ads people see.
You can't really control the
volatility on the ad revenues.
So you can only manage it by
increasing your number of games
as the business grows.
So that was the core reason
why we wanted to switch.
And we have used
our Merge Mechanic
that we developed
in other games,
like "Merged" and "Merge Town."
And we used it in
our "Merge Dragons."
It was the core of the game.
But we've used it.
We merged it with a camp
so that people actually
have items that
they've merged up,
and items that they
actually wanted to keep.
So has then turned into a
higher retention, higher
engagement, higher
output game eventually.
ADI HADDAD: And when did
it happen, that decision?
EREN YANIK: So this was
around early last year.
This was around actually
end of 2016 probably.
So at that point, we had
three casual hyper games.
And we had realized that
every new game actually
boosted your revenue, but
the exponential growth
was not there.
It was almost more linear.
So what happened
was we decided to go
to the next stage
we need to have
a game on top grossing charts.
We need to have a game that
has a stable number of DAU,
people that you acquire
and stick with you.
It's not like the
leech bucket example.
Like people actually go
in and then they leave.
We wanted the more longer
term engagement with them.
And then we have decided to open
up a studio in London actually.
So up until that time
we were in Istanbul.
And we set up the company
and hired everybody
we hired at that point there.
But to do the switch
into IAP, you also
need people who have
done this before,
and people with more
expertise, more experience.
And then London
overall is a city
that's very attractive,
that you can actually
have these people join
you, join the team,
and then work on this game.
So that's what we did.
And launched "Merge Dragons"
from our London office,
from our London studio.
And we launched it
in June of last year.
So from then on,
constantly iterated
the game, added new features.
Even today, I think
the LTV is probably
three times what it used to
be when we first launched it.
ADI HADDAD: So
other than opening
an office in London, what
were the next steps following
that decision.
What did you need to
change the company?
start from scratch?
EREN YANIK: I mean,
at that point,
so we knew what we were good at.
And we knew what we required
to also improve on our side.
Like we were people, Gram
Games, with the exception of me,
is a very developer
oriented management base.
So I think we were very good
in like going to the code.
Let's work on this
for two nights, then
get it out of the way.
Let's just have
like four Red Bulls
and then do this
type of a mindset.
But I think we did not have
the ideas about the business
management, the layers, and the
typical performance management.
So up until that
point, we said, let's
keep the culture we built.
Let's keep the good things
about having a startup mindset.
And it's the type of people that
when something stops working,
they always open it up
and see, what's wrong?
Like tinkering.
Like always going
into the details.
So we tried to get people who
shared this vision, shared
this mindset, but with people
who also have done this
previously with the IAP games.
So not to reinvent the
wheel, so to speak.
So that's what we
tried to bring in.
And we also brought maybe about
10 people from our Istanbul
studio to London, and then hired
around 20 more people directly
to our London office.
But these people
are people who have
worked on level
designers, people who have
worked on character designs.
For an IAP game, these
things really matter.
In a hyper casual, I
think, the core thing
is, do you give enough
feedback to the players,
or is it really enough
differentiation?
But you don't
really focus on when
you level up does the
character get very different?
Or you don't really focus
on a longer term engagement.
But you focus on your
retention metrics, like D1, D7.
So we hired people
with this expertise
and combined them, while
trying to maintain our company
culture.
And it seemed to
work well I guess.
ADI HADDAD: And can you
share a little bit more
about what exactly is different
in developing an IAP based game
compared to an ad based game?
What kind of metrics do you
look at when you do that?
EREN YANIK: I think it almost
feels to us, like an IAP
game feels closer to
making a movie than almost
making a hyper casual game.
I mean, it's a very
extreme example.
But we made "1010"
in actually 10 hours.
So it was a hyper casual game.
But I think it literally
took like a Thursday
morning, an idea, and by
Thursday evening the game
was ready.
We put it on the market.
We saw good numbers, and
then we launched the game.
But IAP is a different story.
Because you don't
really make your money
based on your averages.
You make money
based on your tail.
What that means is on
a hyper casual game,
you actually see D1
retention, D7 retention.
What's our average revenue
per our user per day?
Whereas in an IAP game,
at the end of the day
you focus on the top 5% of
your most engaged players.
So your average
player is not directly
correlated with your
average revenue.
So you actually care
about your top 5%,
top 10% of your engaged players.
How is their experience?
So comments matter more.
Ratings matter more.
Communities matter more.
All of these things.
Like one rating
or one review you
read somewhere could have really
extensive implications for you.
So that's why you need
to be very much more,
I think, almost iterative.
In a hyper casual game
it's almost like trading,
like you acquire users.
They play the game
for a few days.
They leave.
And then you watch that.
Whereas in an IAP game with
a higher long term retention,
it becomes like an
overall experience almost.
Like how is this person
now on their day 35?
What type of dragons they
see, what type of items
they interact with?
We always have like our
junior, mid, high level
player, where they're at
when they're experienced,
how much more time are
they expected to spend?
What is their level
of engagement?
How is that varying?
So those things
are very different.
What we tried to bring them
in from our past experience
with hyper casual games
is, it's very hard
to launch an IAP game fast.
And we're not still
perfect at it.
But what you can do
is you could take
certain loops and
certain mechanics
that you know that work,
put them out first, and then
D1, D7, see how they do.
Like set more
intermediary expectations,
KPIs on what you
think you should have.
And only then, act on it.
That, for us, is the similarity.
But the core difference is more
about engagement rather than
averages.
ADI HADDAD: OK.
And in retrospect, other than
the acquisition by Zynga,
were you happy with
what happened following
the launch of "Merge Dragons?"
EREN YANIK: We were very happy.
And I think even
internally, you share things
at a different level
with your players
when it's a more immersive game.
Because I don't how many people
here played "1010" or "Six!",
but those are the games
that you don't feel--
like you're never like
a crazy "1010" fan.
Like it's the type of game you
would play that wouldn't really
intimidate you.
You would play it for
a few minutes in a day,
and then put your phone down.
But in "Merge Dragons,"
you really see
people who are
fans of that game,
even more than you are, as
the person who made the game.
Right.
You see people who draw,
submit dragon requests, who
have ideas, who spent many
hours on a day on that game.
Those things really, I
think, emotional fulfillment
is much higher, in that sense.
The teams that work on it,
the ownership they feel
is also much higher.
I think on hyper
casual, it's more almost
about like, you make a game.
Try it.
Ship it.
And it's almost like you have no
personal connection whatsoever,
because there's a high chance
that that game will not
be launched.
Whereas in an IAP game
it's about the feature
you're adding.
What about if we
add this chest here?
What happens if we
add the ship here,
and that brings
goodies to our players?
It's much more of a
deeper discussion.
And it's a live product
at the end of the day.
Yeah.
ADI HADDAD: OK.
So we need to close that
part of the session.
It was really interesting.
So thank you, Eren, for
sharing that with the audience.
And just to conclude
this session, which
is a little bit about
diversifying your revenue
streams.
And if you have any questions,
and if you need help with that,
feel free to reach out to
Google Play team members.
And we'll be happy to
help you with that.
And we have some time
for questions now.
So we are open for
questions, if there are any.
Yeah.
Over there.
Do you have a mic?
No.
Just a second.
The mic is on the way.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
My question is, do you
believe that the combination
of enough purchases and
enough advertisement
is beneficial at all times?
Because what you can see
in the top grossing games,
like strategy games,
over 70% rely totally
on in-app purchases only.
They don't have
in-app advertisement.
So why do you think
they're doing it?
And if you believe
that, perhaps,
this in-app advertisement would
break their in-app purchases
ecosystem?
ADI HADDAD: Do you
want to answer that?
EREN YANIK: Yeah.
So a very good question.
I mean, up until August
we did not have any ads
on "Merge Dragons."
So it was fully IAP based.
In August we've added
the rewarded option.
The ads revenues,
there's a bit of,
I'd say almost a lack of
transparency on the way today
you get your ad revenues
on a per player basis.
Like you can't see
how much revenue you
get for one of your players.
So it's very hard to actually
allocate your ad revenues
into players, and
then compare if it
leads to any
cannibalization or not,
because this person watches ads.
So that's why you go
with manual filters.
You either filter the
number of videos they see,
or the number of players that
are able to watch the videos.
If they make a payment,
they take them out
of the rewarded video.
What we did was we capped
the number of videos
that people can watch.
And only capped it, I think,
at two per our players.
That's why for us, and we
could see the revenues,
and it actually added an
incremental benefit to the time
where we had the videos to
the time we did not have,
versus the time where we had.
And I think it's
a choice really.
It depends also how you
monetize your player base,
like where you want to
give that rewarded option
to your players.
To us it's been
beneficial so far.
ADI HADDAD: We have one more
question if we have any.
One more.
No?
Last chance.
OK.
Ah.
Yeah.
Over there.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Two simple
questions, if possible.
The first.
What is the split in your
audience between women and men
in "Merge Dragons?"
And the second, how do
you, if it's possible,
exactly track the numbers
of revenue from IAP
and ads when you're
changing something?
Thanks.
EREN YANIK: Thank you.
The men versus women
split, we don't
collect extensive
information from our players.
But based on, I
think, where we see
with people who log
on using social media,
we think it's around 65% female.
And we don't do anything
specific about this.
I think based on our
current marketing
and currently what
we think is optimized
marketing that this is the
audience that we ended up with.
So it skews female.
And the second
question was, I think,
it was how do we
see ads versus IAPs.
ADI HADDAD: How do you see the
impact of change in the game?
EREN YANIK: Yeah.
So when we generally
add a new feature,
we leave around a month
or longer testing periods.
It's harder to do
the A/B test on ads.
Because ads, again,
many things change.
And it's hard.
What we're lucky
with is that we have
eight other ad based games.
So we can also compare
the ad revenue,
the CPMs between those
games and this game.
Like does it really change
when we change something?
Does the ad revenue here
grow more than the others?
IAP is generally easier to see,
like per player, where they're
at in their game, you
could see if something
increases or decreases, you
can track it more effectively.
But ads, you have to group.
That's the core problem.
ADI HADDAD: OK.
Thanks, everyone.
Thanks, Eren.
EREN YANIK: Thank you.
ADI HADDAD: Hope it was
interesting for you guys.
And that's it for that session.
EREN YANIK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]